- During my time at McKinsey,
I helped in designing
the training programs
for the new consultants.
In these training programs,
communication was always one
of the most important skills.
It was common feedback of
all the senior consultants
and all the partners
that the number one topic
where young consultants needed training on
and where they need to be
developed by the training programs
is how to communicate effectively.
How to say the things in the right way.
One of the most fundamental
concepts that we taught
in these training programs is the concept
of top-down communication.
In this video, I'm going to talk
about what top-down communication is.
We are jointly going to
work through one exercise
that I trust will really teach you
how top-down communication works.
So by watching this video,
I trust that you will build
a very important skill set
that will hugely benefit you,
not only if you work in consulting,
but pretty much in every other role
in the professional context,
and probably even in your
private life as well.
Welcome to another coffee break
with me here on my channel, Firm Learning.
If you're new here with this channel,
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years in your career.
But now without further
ado, let's jump into it.
I will teach you how to
talk like a consultant.
And this video will be
structured in two parts.
First, I'm going to talk
about what top-down
communication actually is.
And then second, we're going
to do an exercise together
to really help you engrain
this principle in your head.
So what is top-down communication?
And if you read all the books
and articles about that,
you will find out that there
are lots of definitions.
Many people claiming different things
to be top-down communication.
So I really want to simplify it for you.
So in my experience,
what this really comes
down to is two things.
Namely, first in your communication
to focus on the results,
to focus on the content.
To only focus on the things
that really matter to your audience.
And second, always
starting your communication
with the key message, with the key result
that you want to communicate
to your audience.
When people talk about
top-down communication,
they often also use the
word pyramid principle.
The reason why you talk about a pyramid
where you have a pyramid structure
is because you need to imagine
and structure in your head
all the different facts,
information, all the details
that you want to talk
about in a pyramidal form.
So at the bottom, there are
all the underlying arguments,
there are the details.
But then based on this fundament,
you would then draw some conclusions,
you would then draw some results.
And then on the very
top is the key message
that you really wanna share
and that you really wanna talk about
and the main error that many people do
is not starting with this
result, with this key message,
but rather starting with
all the individual details,
with all the little arguments
that then your whole case is composed of,
and then only in the very end
to then draw the conclusion from it.
So they pretty much
turn the pyramid around
and this for many different reasons
is not considered effective communication.
And if you want to learn more about that,
I talked a lot about
this in my first video
in communication skills.
I will link it somewhere
above here for you
if you want to check it out.
So hopefully this clarifies
what top-down communication is,
but now to make it even
more tangible for you,
let's deep dive into a practical example.
And this was an exercise that we did a lot
with young consultants, that
we used a lot at McKinsey
to train consultants in the organization.
And you can imagine the overall setting
to be something like this:
You as a consultant
sitting in the team room,
just mind your business doing your work,
and then suddenly the CEO of the company
or another senior client of the company,
or maybe even a partner is
walking into your team room
and asking you, "Hey,
Heinrich, how is it going?
Where do we stand? What's
the current status?"
And this is a question
that hits many people kind of off guard
because you were just in the middle
of something completely else.
And now you are required to
in front of a senior person
really concisely, briefly,
and to the point answering such a question
of where you stand with a specific task.
So now let's jump into this exercise
and let's imagine you finding
yourself in such a situation,
and the context is as follows
and I'm reading from the slide here.
So you are working on a market entry study
and the objective of the study is
to assess market entry opportunities
for a new product line.
So the client tasked you to work on that.
And of course it could easily also
be just the internal team, so
not necessarily a consultant,
but an employee of the company
working on this specific task.
And now in order to do that,
you conducted interviews
with lots of different
internal and external experts
to learn more about this topic.
You analyzed lots of data,
you worked with different departments,
with the finance department,
with the marketing department.
Probably the preliminary result,
the first indication that you have is
that the market entry in
France would be a good fit
and you're basing this result just based
on all these interviews that you conducted
and all these data analysis that you did.
And now, indeed, the CEO walks in
and asks you to give a project summary.
He says, "Hey, how is it going?
You work on the market
entry project, right?
What is the status on that?"
And now the question is,
how do you answer to that?
And now I just want to take you a moment
and ideally just grab a pen,
grab a piece of paper and just
jot down a couple of thoughts
on how you would reply to that.
And of course, if you want,
you can just briefly pause
the video to do that.
Okay, so I hope to do just exactly that.
And now I want to guide
you through two examples,
or two examples of potential answers.
And then let's briefly discuss
what is going well with this example,
and maybe what isn't so much.
Let's start with example number one
as a potential answer that
somebody could have given.
And this answer goes as follows.
"So the last weeks we have
been very busy on the project.
First, I talked to Tom from
finance to get the market data.
However, when looking at the numbers,
we realized that marketing
has the better numbers,
with the new marketing data set
together with interviews we conducted,
we were able to get a good overview
of the different market opportunities.
At the moment, it looks like
France will be a good fit
for our project, though this
is still work in progress."
So this could be an answer
and, from my experience, this is an answer
that many people would
give in such a situation.
So let's just dissect it a bit.
What is special? What is
characteristic about this answer?
And this answer consists of the stating
all the different steps that you did,
all the different steps that you did
to come to this conclusion.
Just saying, okay, first I
did that, then I did this.
Then I talked to this guy,
then I talked to that guy.
So lots of work that I put in,
I crunched all these numbers.
And in the end, there is a
specific result that we have now.
And of course now, if you look
into this, this is something
that you would not consider
talk-down communication.
Okay guys, this is not
top-down communication
but it's the opposite, it's
bottom up communication
because you start by
giving all the details,
by giving all the nitty-gritty facts
and steps and arguments.
This is communication that
is based on the process.
It's based on the things that you did,
but not so much about the result,
and in a business setting,
in most cases you want to
avoid communicate like that.
And the main reason is that,
frankly, the CEO won't care,
the CEO will not care to whom you talk to,
whose data set you analyzed.
These are all just details
that in most cases are
just not of interest,
but instead he will just trust you
that if you tell him something,
of course you will have done the research,
of course you will have done the analysis,
but in general, this
is just not the answer
that C-level executives of
companies are interested in.
Let's contrast this now
with a second example
of how such a question
could have been answered.
And again, let me just
read it out for you.
So, here, an answer could go like this:
"Our current hypothesis is that France
would be the best fit for our project.
This is based on three reasons.
First, our consumer research shows
that French consumers would
appreciate our offering.
Second, the competitive
landscape in France
is not yet developed.
We will be the first with this offering.
Third, our logistics and
distribution capabilities
are well set up to serve
the French market."
And now, again, let's first dissect this.
What is special about this answer?
So first, this answer
now doesn't talk at all
about the little steps in between
that you took to get to a result.
Instead, this answer starts
by giving the result,
it starts by sharing
your current hypothesis.
And so pretty much if
the CEO would need now
to leave the meeting just
after a couple of seconds,
if now would have a phone
call popping up on his phone
and he wouldn't be able to
now continue listening to you,
he already just with the first
sentences of your answer,
he would already know the result,
he would already know
what your hypothesis is.
And of course now, if
he would have the time
to continue listening to you,
he would not only have the answer,
but he also also would be able
to hear the top three reasons
that you based your the conclusion,
that you based your answer on.
And this of course now is
information that the CEO
or other senior level executives
in the corporation will be interested in.
This is the type of
communication that is top-down.
It focuses on the content or
for the results that you work,
but not on the process.
This is exactly what top-down
communication is all about.
And I would always encourage you
to communicate your
results in this fashion.
So why is it so difficult for many people
to on-the-spot embrace this
top-down communication skill
and just communicate in that way?
Probably this is for three reasons.
First, it's just the natural
way to talk about it,
to use this bottom-up approach, right?
It's just the order of
how you did the things.
First you did this this, then
this, then this, then this.
So this is just a natural way
of how you tell something.
But, of course, still,
it's not the best way.
So only because this
is your first impulse,
take a second, take a step
back and just reflect.
The second reason why
I believe many people
rather use bottom-up than
top-down communication
is because it really stresses
all the work that you did.
It shows all your sweat, all
the things, all the long hours
all the mental energy
that you put into a task.
But the CEO will not care how
long you worked last night
or how smart you were by
coming up with the idea
of now hitting up the marketing guy.
This is not what will interest
the senior-level guys.
They will care about the results
so don't bore them with the process.
Don't try to impress them
with the long hours that you worked.
And the third reason is
that people are messy
in their head, right?
People for themselves often
do not have it crystal clear
why they are recommending something.
What the underlying reasons
are when you come up
with a conclusion or
with a recommendation,
and so make sure just also for
the quality of the thinking,
for the quality of your documents,
that it's always crystal
clear for yourself,
just to start with,
what really the result is that
you want to put out there,
and what also the main
underlying arguments are
that are supporting your conclusions.
So I hope this video
helped you to understand
what top-down communication is all about.
If you have any more
questions on this topic,
leave me a comment below
in the comment section,
and I will do my very best
to answer every single
comment that you have.
If you want to learn even more
about this type of
professional communication,
I have a book that I can
really recommend you.
The book is called "The Pyramid Principle:
Logic in Writing and Thinking."
It is written by Barbara Minto.
She is an ex-McKinsey employee herself.
And this book is one of the best sellers
of professional communication.
If you want to check it out,
I included a link to the book below
in the video description,
I can highly recommend it.
And now if you want to
do me a little favor,
if you took any value out of this video,
please hit the like button.
This really helps me with
the YouTube algorithm.
And of course, if you want to
see even more content from me,
please subscribe to this
channel for more content.
I release at least one
video every Saturday.
If you want to see even
more content from me,
I also have an Instagram channel
where I post content almost every day.
My handle is Firm Learning.
If you want to read even more from me,
I also have an email mailing list
with even more regular
content on these topics.
You can find a sign-up link
to the mailing list below
in the video description.
Thank you for watching guys,
I very much appreciate your time.
Hope you're enjoying your weekend
and talk to you soon again next Saturday.